morning session today it's our first
tech guy Kinder it's I believe a very
fresh result yeah
didn't complexly get out of the oven yet
but yeah
oh hi good morning
um
yeah so let's see if I can pronounce
everything in the title this is a
polynomial
result in SL2
of the of finite fields fq
um
did I say to sln fq well you know the
boat is going uh yeah and this is John's
with everyone in the norm so I didn't
manage to say everything okay
uh so okay
uh
so
this line of work
originates or at least
questions
uh at least that's what I'm told it's in
French
by Burger Lugoff from 39 and uh
I think the latest
is sundos
from 2012 a
so
the question of the problem that we'll
start that they're studying is the
following you have a subset
of if Q to the n
Q maybe Prime say and and
a large number
so this is a set of
density
Alpha
and you want to study the structure of
what happens when you add and subtract a
form itself uh
so here is a
theorem
if you take a minus a plus a and again
minus a
the order doesn't matter it's a billion
but it's for seeing the future
this contains
contains a a Subspace
B if you think of this as a vector space
uh of code dimension
which is a
something like one over
a alpha to the fourth power
um
so yeah
that's the
um
a billion version a
sorry
this is q q and p o
mentioned one of the other photos
so I think the I think it's called
Dimension and
and this is
[Music]
yeah so if the dimension is small the
code Dimension is large it's a small
symbol
sorry okay
this is
foreign
[Music]
okay yeah so
yeah fine and this is like a quasi
polynomial uh result because the the
density
uh of the Subspace the relative density
uh
uh in inside this group is a quasi
polynomial in the density of the
original set a and it's interesting to
improve this to get a polynomial density
in the density of a
uh and uh they will do it
in a different group
so uh
yeah so think of the
which is actually q q there's a large
constant maybe and and
much larger than they are going to
Infinity then I think that's the good uh
parameters that one should consider
and we consider
a similar
problem
on a sln
Q
um
I'll tell you what the this group is
it's it's not a billion
and because it's not a billion it comes
with more power like multiplication is
somehow more powerful in on a billion
sets then uh and therefore we can get a
better result but it also comes with
more responsibility because
groups
uh
come with representation Theory and
representation theory is an old and huge
subject that was studied at least from
the beginning of the 20th century
uh so I won't need a lot today and I
guess you're not going to be surprised
if I tell you that the results that we
need from a recent representation Theory
we just used a result that already
existed but what may surprise you is
that they existed only in the last few
years uh these are new results in
representation Theory
um
Okay so
let's talk about this group first uh
and a few
this is a sub group of gln fq
which is a subset of just matrices and
by n matrices over the field
fq
this is
uh I think of this as an a billion
a group
uh gln fq so this is just a set of
matrices you can add them and subtract a
gln fq you can multiply these are the
inverted invertible matrices so you can
multiply and you can uh do the opposite
of multiplying whatever that is uh
and uh so this is uh impossible
wait it says and those are the matrices
which are invertible but also we have
the terminal to work
um and
maybe we'll need that intuition later so
I'll just say the number of matrices
here or just all matrices it's Q to the
N squared
and the number of matrices here
it's uh
not much different
it's whatever we had before divided by
maybe Q square or something like that
and the size of this group
is smaller than that of course but also
not very much it's a it's GL
it's whatever you have in Glam
divided by Q or human Swan because you
can have all kinds of determinants but
you only fix one
okay uh so yeah so invertible
determinant one matrices and the main
theorem
is that if a is a subset
group
density
it is at least a q to the C and squared
so a minor sale I write C to mean that
there's some Global constant for which
this holds and this constant will always
be C but it will always be different
than the other constants
so yeah so Q to the minus C N squared
means the density can be as low as
polynomial is small in the size of the
book
then if you take
a a and the inverse of a and also a and
then the inverse of a and you multiply
them all so this is all the inverses or
elements in a then this contains
a subgroup
of density
let me say let me call it g of density
that is at least
uh
okay new of a is the relative density of
a like the something between 0 and 1
actually greater than Q to the minus C
and squared
and this is a global constant
so therefore a polynomial result
and I can say more I can say something
about the structural of how of G so
moreover
G
is of form
G equals
okay
see hopefully
LK times C to the minus one
foreign
so it is the adjoint of LK LK is a
subgroup of uh of slnq
so
this is just an element in the book
[Music]
would not be the first one to lie down
to write on the board
yeah and and LK is a very
simple
well simple is a charge term but an easy
to describe a subgroup
of a slnq
NK consists of all the matrices that
have
the cable cable identity Matrix
and then zeros
and then whatever here
so Heats
it can be anything
uh formed well
see I don't know
SL n minus k
uh over fq
because I gives 1 to the determinant so
to get overall one you get you need a
matrix so
n minus K in this case so yeah so LK is
not just a nice to describe a subgroup
it's actually
homomorphic
[Music]
isomorphic thank you so uh
so the same type of group
that we started with
um
so
I want to name
this so I'll start by just saying that
um
let's let's understand what LK is
okay
is the set
it stabilizes
the vectors E1 up to e k
in two ways if you multiply it by E1 to
APK from the right they remain you want
to to Decay and so and also from the
left so these are actually 2K
constraints on LK uh so formal
uh both sides
um
so something like c l k
three minus one stabilizers
okay other
detectors in the same way
like whatever you whatever you need to
put here to get E1 up to EK
and also it's a group right it's an
adjoint of a group it's a group we call
it we didn't focus group it yet but
and quality 2K
would because it's good
because it's both an umbrella it is you
know you decide if you're in the set by
looking at a set of
K constraints and seeing if they are
satisfied so it's an overhead of 2K
constraints but it's also a group so
that's
um
were you erased I see you're about to
race this board
as much earlier okay so what was the
point of you writing these conclusions
on the bottom like they're not
um just was this just yeah so full okay
so for now it's just so you know if you
want some information about what sln is
and maybe you're more familiar with the
display I thought you were saying that
this is a like the additive group and
then on the right it's like no so I said
that the set of matrices I think of is
an additive group
because like it's not a book with
respect to another application but here
it is a group with respective so here it
is
the book action is multiplying two
matrixes I shouldn't be able to get
intuition for the multiplicative group I
think about the attitude that's a very
good point yeah
uh maybe we'll get to that yeah in
theory there's no intuition like yeah so
this has nothing to do with that on the
face of it okay so guys can you explain
why this is obviously false for gln
uh
uh no
it's not false Soldier it's just easier
to work with
yeah Dylan works the same with
the difference is that Jalen has some
annoying characters
that's that's why I'm working with this
then does it matter the disease are in
sln or gln
no
ah do the Seas change not the C sorry I
don't know what this character is I want
to see see let's call it
yeah so this see
uh no if you're
the same if it's in jail yeah yeah it
doesn't matter
like they don't expect the right so
Jalen has these slns embedded in it
exactly because of this season and
that's why it's sort of enough to just
talk about this maybe this access
foreign
[Music]
so if I
look at the double crochet so I multiply
NK maybe from C on the left and by C
from the right
so this is again a set of two people so
it's just that they are not on the same
Vector not on the same vectors and it's
not about fixing them if they are
changing them but still it's a concern
so this is a 2K good
over it
uh
yeah I think I said everything that I
need about this
subgroups of a cell in fq so
let's talk about how to prove this
bogalyugov
result
um
so the poof scheme has a I don't know I
think four steps let's see
so the first
is not really doing anything it's just
definition uh
we are going to prove things for Global
subjects so I need to tell you what a
global subset is there are various
definitions that we use I'll just
write to one so a a subset of sln
Q is say all global
if
on
any k
umbrellate
so I tell you I told you what a good
over it is I didn't tell you what the k
over rate is which is maybe not so good
but it doesn't matter
the relative
density
I mean you can imagine what this might
be the relative density of a
is doesn't think so if you if you add
constraints you go into a subset of slnq
the density does not go by too much so
it's bounded by R to the K times the
origin original
density of a
uh so that's a definition
and then once you know what the global
set is then you can
aim to prove a theorem
about global growth
which says that
if a set is global then it grows a lot
to when you multiply it by itself
obviously it's not true necessarily if
it's not Global it can be just a
subgroup we know that slnq has subworks
and then it will not go but if it is
global uh yeah so the coupled version so
now we have two sets a and b
Excel and a few
and suppose that
are both a
maybe Q to some
of it
Zeta that's let's say that this is
better a cues a queue to the that time
global
so Zeta is a small construct
um
okay so we have two sets that are Global
uh
if okay I'm kneeling now but still
it doesn't count so if the measures of
this set is at least Q to the minus C N
squared
and go here then
um
yeah the
measure of the product
so you can get almost all things by just
multiplying an element of a by an
element of B so they can be quite small
and still their product is quite large
so this is the global growth theorem
and as a corollary you get that
under the same conditions if you take A
and B and multiply them and then
multiply what you got by itself then
this is already everything
this is this is a standout exercise that
yeah
so that in the global growth what is
your choice about
q24 yeah
so I purchased this book
I don't know it's supposed to be here to
The Zeta n well that is a small concept
another seems a testable sorry it's not
the same
yeah it's a it's a new constant uh
maybe service is due to the end Global
what
these episodes yes right that was my
next comment Q to the constant times and
it's sort of like the the right thing to
expect so they should that you should
expect because every set is Q to then
Global each constraint like if you fix
the vector one say this Vector needs to
go to that Vector this reduces the
number of matrices by a factor of Q to
the n uh and so if you're just a subset
of this set then still your measure goes
only by a factor of Q to the n uh so so
to be Global they need to grow a little
less than just being a subset over of an
umbrella
so
uh
yeah
well in some sense this proves that this
cannot be because if there was a sub sub
group that was not uh yeah so so that's
a consequence of
yeah so I guess right so I guess every
subwoof okay
[Music]
content
okay
but that statement uh has a proof only
video
or sorry that statement you just made
about every subgroup has a group only
appear what you grouped or
uh I guess you can prove it in other
ways I'm
sure if you think
I bet that if you think about it you'll
find something less something moderate
than going through all their
representations
okay
um
right okay so what is left uh if
A and B are Global sake of b and a to
the minus one right so if a is global
then also a minus 1 is global and then a
times a to the minus one is almost
everything and then a a minus one A A
minus one is almost everything uh
and we are not done because of the other
case which is where a is not Global uh
so if
so here's a
another theorem uh another structural
theorem uh if uh
same subset of slnq is not
uh Q to the same data
and global
and then
we just okay what does it mean it means
that there's an umbrella to where it is
more concentrated so we'll go into that
one and then if it's not if it's still
not Global we go further and so on and
so forth eventually we'll find uh an
umberator it is global and that's what I
want to say and then
it is
Global relative
to
a good
um
through tea will be right for some tea
uh
so let's call it h this umbrella
so H is of the form c l t PSI
and also
the measure of H is going to be the
measure of a
to some constant
and together this uh these parts uh
complete the proof because
you have a subset
either it's Global and then AI minus one
A A minus one gives you everything or if
not then it's Global in some
smaller
umbilrate
and then
when you multiply a bar by a minus one
okay
um
foreign
so when you multiply
uh
a by a minus 1 this is going to be a
subset of
so
all at least
it's going to be dense in
it may also contain other things but
it's going to be dense in a h times H to
the minus one so H time H to the minus 1
is you get c l t
and then PSI but then you multiply by H
inverse so PSI minus one LT to the minus
one but it's a group LT to the minus one
is the same thing and then C to the
minus one
and these things cancel and you just get
C
LT because LT times LT is LT say minus
one so you get that a times a minus to
the minus one is dense in a Google lot
uh and that's what we wanted and so it's
dense in a gumball and then if you
multiply It Again by itself you'll get
all the Google forgotten and that's it
you have the theorem
okay right so we have these four parts
and one of them is just a definition so
there's not much left uh the challenging
part is This Global Golf out
um so
so I'll talk about this one
the rest of the talk
um
how do you prove
that the product of two sets
is large
I guess
one option
is to look at the convolution
of the uh of the indicator of these sets
the indicators of these sets
but for that we need to say what the
convolution is
on the solution
so if
f and g
from sln fq
to maybe
the complex numbers and
I'm interested in the case that f is the
indicator of A and G is the indicator of
B but of course the definition is just
General
so the convolution of F and and G at the
point x remember that X is a matrix
is defined to be an expectation of a
random Matrix in a cell and if Q of
uh F of Y
G of inverse y
that's the convolution
um
and
let's suppose that f is the indicator of
A and G is the indicator of B and try to
understand what we have here so
um
this expectation over Y and Y to the
minus one X the product of these things
is X and this is really just an
expectation over random pairs whose
product is X uh so and and sorry to take
two elements and if F of Y is one it
means that Y is in a and if G of that is
zero then it means that this is in B and
therefore I get a non-zero so f
convolution g x if it is non-zero it
means that X belongs
to the product a b and if I want to show
that the product a b covers everything
then one option is to is to show
that
that the convolution
of f and g is uh
is more or less
a constant function hopefully that is
not the zero function if f convolution g
is the constant function it means even
more it means that every every element
in the group is obtained more or less
the same number of times as a product of
A and B
so yeah so I so in order to prove that a
times B is almost everything it's enough
to show that if a convolution g is
almost constant
uh
and and so the main
maybe technical Lemma
that we need to prove is that uh
uh if a and b are subsets of slmq and
they'll global
again with it
Zeta times anything parameter and with
density
at least uh same as before Q to the
minus C and N squared
uh then
right so this is these are the same
conditions as the global growth theorem
then I want to say that the
L2 Norm
so I take the expectation of the
expectation of G these are just the
relative measures of A and B
and I take the difference from the
convolution of f with G then the tone
Norm of that is bounded by
some parameter which is very small times
the expectations of f times the
expectation of G
right so uh right so the difference
between them is very small compared just
to uh to the multiplication of the
measures this means that if that a times
B covers almost everything
and we just need to discuss how this can
be pulled
um
okay and and for that I need to tell you
about representations
try to
save the minimal information possible so
that the experts are not Bold and the
non-experts are not
is startled so
so maybe start with an example some
examples that you know so if G is a bull
a
a billion
group
then function from G
to the complex numbers can be written
actually Nick
in only one way as an uh
as a combination of characters where the
characters come from this character set
ER
and these characters have some relations
to the structure of the group
if G is a product of stuff
then there is therefore Stein F can be
written as a sum of f equals s where s
is a subset of one to n so something
similar also holds a for a general if a
final refiner groups so G finite
group
so we know that a function
from G
to the complex numbers
can be
written
as a f
equals sum over
same as before G hat but now it's the
set of representations not the set of
characters and uh
usually denoted by raw seminal letters
and then
I have the Rope out of f so this is a
way to write functions over
non-abillion groups
and again the structure
of these f4s
is related to the structure of the of
the group sorry in a bit a bit more
about that so in general the set of all
functions from sln fq this actually
holds for any a finite group can be
written
is an also normal
also normal direct some
some of subspaces
wo
um
and
uh and F4
is just the projection
of f onto this space wo
and uh
and the law each law is called an
irreducible
a representation
and
wo is called the isotip is a typical
uh space
of this saw
and
and so far these are just names I didn't
tell you anything about the relation of
all of this to the group stock show but
that's coming uh
yeah
uh so
yeah what does what are the relations of
all these things to the group structure
so first of all there is a relation
between the group and the functions from
the group to see this relation is by an
action so sln uh fq or any other group
it acts on L2 of sln
uh fq
here is how if I have a matrix
PSI
it operates on a function
from the left
by giving us a new function
so PSI of f will give it the point x the
value of f with the point Chi times x
so this is just a shift right if I have
a function over a group I can shift it
by an element of the group that's what
that that's what this action is and
actually you can also
multiply F by X I from the right that's
another action this will give it a point
x the value of x of F at the point x
times PSI to the minus one never mind
the minus one though
um
and here is the relation to the group
structure
the W was
they are invariant
under
the group actions
if you take a function from wo and you
apply any of the group actions with nxc
it remains a function in in wo
and actually
they are the minimal
invariant spaces below that you just
have the zero spaces
that's then that's a complete definition
of these W rows
sorry
yeah I hit that
right so it's not really what tovoy is
here but uh
but somehow once you once you look at
this minimal invariant subspaces each of
them you can partition it to spaces that
are invariant just from the left or just
from the right and these are
and these are
representations of the group
the terrazomorphic tool
uh
okay
and uh
okay and one more thing uh important I
want to talk about the dimensions of the
wos they make a lot of difference
so there is a dimension of law they
represent the uh which is and it is just
the square root
so this is
not a Subspace I just Define a dimension
for it and it's just a square root
of the dimension of this actual Subspace
um
and yeah okay but how is this Con
related to uh convolutions or functions
well
you need to do some work but not too
much
um
oh okay sorry before that here is an
observation
uh
for every Row the space wo is invaluant
okay undo
the group
action
why is that
oh sorry
under sorry right group action I said
under a convolution
convolution with effect with the
function
F but for any function if if you take a
a function here and you take the
convolution with f you get again a
function from wo
ons on both sides if you yeah if you
want to be fancy ER
and the reason is that there is another
way to look at the convolution if it at
least if it remains on the board
yeah so it was F of Y times G of Y minus
1 x and there was some expectation here
uh so G of Y minus 1 x is just a shift
of G by y by y to the minus one
so if G is from a w row this function is
also from wo and I take a linear
combination of such functions with
weights that come from f
uh and so yeah and so this observation
is true and now
if you did a bit of work
uh
you get the form the following formula
for the convolution of f with g
uh
the convolution of f with G so you're
not supposed to see where it's true but
it's not far from where we are right now
there's not much to do
you can a partition FNG according to the
Raw
parts so it's the sum of f rope out
convolution G
about
uh
and you can do a little more
to see how this is related to what we
want there is one drawing part in
particular which is interesting we said
that the constant functions the set of
constants or maybe we should have said
the set of constant functions of course
they are invariant under shift so they
form one of the W rows let's call it wtl
for w trivial uh so you can write it as
let's separate out the trivial
representation so we have f equals
trivial convolution g equals trivial
plus the sum
of all the other rows of the same thing
and the trivial part of f what is it
it's the projection of f on the constant
functions
it's just the average
or the expectation of f
right the projection of f on constant
functions it's just the average of f so
I have the expectation of f times the
expectation of G which is exactly what I
want plus other things that I don't want
some of the rows of f equals or
convolution g equals o
and I would very like very much like to
show that these things are small
um
right so so let's look at
the norm of this thing the norm of
f equals or
I cannot change the market but maybe I
can switch another one
uh
so
it's okay
uh right so I have
this sum overall non-trivial rules of
the convolution between F4 and 0 uh
let's I want to bound the norm of that
so let's just look at the these norms
um
and I uh well how can I bound them so
one way is to think of the convolution
with the function as an operator
so this is the operator of convoluting
with f equals row applied to the
function g equals all so the operator
will be called t f equals 0 perhaps
and so the norm of this thing is bounded
by so I have
the same sum as before and and I have
the norm of
the operator Norm of t f equals
times
uh the norm of g equals oh
switch again then okay
I'll try
[Music]
right so
instead of f equals rho I wrote the norm
of the operator that convolutes with f
equals row and then times the norm of
the function g equals all
and now I can do
a fancy step
by
that was first done by sarnak
0 in 91 which is
to evaluate this Norm
using a uh how is it called
yeah I want the trace Norm so you can
you can bound the norm of an operator
using the norm of its multiplication
with its conjugate and its
multiplication with its conjugate is a
self-adjoint and so you know you can
bound that Norm using the eigenvalues
and the eigenvalues you can bound
using a
the trace
and and and it turns out that you get a
bound of the form
uh yeah so the norm of this is bounded
by
uh
f
equals rho gnome divided by the
dimension of raw
square root
yeah and now I have to multiply my g
equals oh
uh this Dimension is because I want
eigen values and I and this is this
turns out to be the trace of this
operator uh and the eigenvalues are
bounded by the trace divided by the
dimension and there's a square root
never mind so somehow you ended up with
like the sports group of actual some
states it's the fourth root of the
dimension yeah but but truly the
dimension of this is the square of the
dimension of that that's so one is the
square root of the one is the square of
that and the other is the square root of
that
that's the right way to think about it
so this thing also does correspond to
some Subspace yeah so the laser yeah
there is an actual Subspace here that
they didn't mention yeah and it appeals
dim more times inside this Subspace
uh
okay did I okay have I made uh uh
yeah okay
so everything we did so far would work
but maybe this would not work at here
and or like where is yeah so in SQL this
Dimension will be one
and you will have made no progress from
here to here you would just get the same
thing
yeah so yeah so I want you to think that
this is a big win that I got this
Dimension here because
if the group is very non a billion
at least intuitively you expect the
dimension of the representations to be
large and then and and those and
therefore when I have this Dimension
View
I hope that it appears everything and I
and I get just a small number and so all
that is left is that if uh convolution G
is the product of the expectations
this is what I would hope
and also it's sort of like the part
that's more not available
[Music]
so small dimensions and I knew that it
won't work
okay and so did you because so far I
didn't use anything about globalness of
the functions
uh so I guess I have time to just tell
you the main
like idea of how to go how to continue
from here and the general scheme is from
uh let me see if I can say names without
looking at my notes uh not the correct
order but
keep us
[Music]
let's see if I was like
I can't find it now we may not stay
I'm sorry yeah
okay so and yeah so their skin was
to take like ideas from analysis
function functions and assign
so idea of how to continue is to assign
a rank
for each
uh
and the second step is to show
that
was with a high rank
um
have
High Dimensions or let's say large
dimensions
right so this is the intuition that we
just said if we if if you're in a pot
that's very non-abillion then the then
the rank of then the rank of War will be
high and also the dimension of or will
be high
and for
right
uh yeah so it's not clear rank is for
now just a saved name
I'll tell you what it is in a second it
will just take a second I think
but anyway for uh was
of low rank
we are going to show that the
if you just project
if
on
was
on on all the sets wo you know the the
some of the spaces wo where the rank of
raw is say smaller than d
then the norm of that
will be small
compared
uh
to the norm of the original f that is
going to be true if f is an indicator of
a global set so now we are using the
globalness so this is called the Level D
inequality for Global functions
and this is the scheme and now you just
have to somehow assign
actual meanings to the saved words and
use some results from a representation
Theory and other results so uh so okay
so the rank
of a
the rank of representation
okay the lack of representation is going
to be the tensor rank
um
which I'm not going to Define but I can
tell you that representations
okay I I will tell you just a second so
first of all
it's called tenderloin
and I'm not going to give you the
official definition but basically uh raw
is of length one if W or the set of this
set of functions are just linear
functions
in the coefficients of the Matrix right
like you have it functions over a set of
matrices as a sln2sq is a set of
matrices uh given as given a matrix you
can apply a linear function to the
coefficients of The Matrix
this is a function of rank one and what
olives in C right so you can see
right so
w wall is a space of functions I didn't
talk about the wall at all right I
talked about W or wo is a set of
functions and it's the and the sum of
all W O's of over all was of like one is
just a set of linear functions
and Rank 2 will be just the set of
polynomials of degree 2 in the
coefficients of the matrices
except the you you the you only take
those to our orthogonal to those big
functions that already appeared in rank
one
and so on so this is so rank is tensor
bank and I told you what it is it's not
really the way it is officially defined
and the definition is from a paper of
guavich and how from a
2017 so that's
fairly new
uh the dimensions of high ranks is
bigger so the dimension of of w wall
turns out to be bigger
than
uh queue to some constant times n times
the rank of war and this is a an even
new result this is
I'm probably not pronouncing anything
correctly from 2020
what all those guys say their names okay
good yeah I had an intuition and
and uh
and the uh so yeah so these things are
fairly new uh and the D level inequality
it's it's from basically for my PayPal I
mean you need to make will but
essentially to do some work but
essentially it comes from a paper of
Ellis myself and the norm from last year
and that PayPal was about you know this
brings me to a question uh from before
that paper is not about SL and Q it's
about the set of the a billion group of
matrices n by n matrices
uh and then we prove the level the
inequality but Level D was defined
completely differently
but still it turns out that the two the
two versions of ranks or levels uh
they are not the same but they are very
very related and we can use the result
from the from the billion group to our
uh to our case what
foreign
type inequality that I actually talked
about in Beyond The Bull and Cube
a few weeks ago
right yeah so if you have like if you
can if you can relate the high Norms of
loadable functions to the low nodes you
can also get a bunch on how much weight
they have how much weight Boolean
functions have on their low degree part
and and in that paper that I mentioned
we've moved a bone only type inequality
for Global functions I think they were
not called Global functions well but
that's what they will
they will call Global function okay
let's thank God again
foreign
[Applause]
thank you